peter uh some news that that has emerged
and this is about the window every day
this is the
this is the pcr test result window where
pretty much everyone who covers the
sport on a national basis tells us per
source
that there were negatives or they were
positive and there's a flood of tweets
from 20 different reporters as to the
day's crop report it's like the it's
like the crop report from trading places
we're waiting for clarence beaks every
morning between between 7 30 and 8
o'clock eastern and we now know that the
titans no new positives which is
positive and the patriots no new
positives either it keeps everything on
track but it doesn't mean that anyone's
out of the woods especially new england
do not assume that everything is fine
and dandy now because stefan gilmore
tested positive on tuesday morning which
means he was quite possibly shedding
virus on the plane home
monday night and in that locker room
it's about a thousand square feet at
arrowhead stadium he was around other
players and they may still be in the
incubation period they could still test
positive tomorrow or sunday or monday in
theory although they don't they
typically don't test on game days
they'll probably test the patriots on
monday and so and that could derail
everything peter so they're not out of
the woods yet
i think the important thing to realize
mike last sunday while writing my column
i wanted to reach out to an infectious
disease specialist i happen to know one
wife of a of a good friend of mine uh dr
celine gander
and
dr gaunder is an infectious disea
disease specialist at nyu
langham hospital
in new york
told me that
when you get exposed to the virus
it's usually on average four to five
days after that exposure
that
the average person would test positive
if
they catch the virus
so what that means in this particular
case i'm assuming
that stefan gilmore's test
was taken on tuesday morning okay in
foxborough
then they find out late tuesday night so
what that means is that
you know tuesday morning midnight 2 a.m
3 a.m whatever time they're on the plane
now we go forward four or five days what
is that four or five days that's sun
that's saturday or sunday
so
i'm not saying that anybody has it or
that anybody uh that there's gonna be an
outbreak i don't know
probably not
but what i am saying is the new england
patriots are not out of the woods yet
yeah you're absolutely right and it's
amazing how many people
don't fully understand that and setting
aside why people don't understand basic
information like that that should have
been shared with us from the get-go back
in march there is a lag just because
you're negative today doesn't mean
you're going to be negative tomorrow and
i've had people say oh i'm fine i was
tested when we tested last week well
that doesn't mean you're fine today that
just means you didn't have it the day
that that and it doesn't mean you you
weren't incubating it the day that you
gave the sample and you think about this
and remember the patriots took two
planes
so staphon gilmore was on the plane with
the people who had close contact with
cam newton those other people who had
close contact with clan cam newton ended
up having close contact
relatively speaking on the same plane
with stefan gilmore and that locker room
in kansas city i mean there's been
plenty of complaints i've gotten this
week from coaches about how small the
visiting team locker rooms are chris
talked yesterday about the the locker
room in kansas city how you can't get
dressed at your locker everyone's
cramped together there so gilmore was
there he was with patrick mahomes face
mask to face mask after the game mahomes
is still in that incubation period
potentially so just because everything's
negative today does not mean it's not
going to take a turn we hope it doesn't
but we need people to be aware we're not
going to act like it doesn't exist
people get mad when we talk about it
peter like we should just ignore it like
ignore it and it'll go away well that's
not the way it works if we haven't
learned that lesson by now we never will
but that's not the way it works
yeah
it's like it's like the letter i got to
my column this week mike from a guy who
said
why do you write so much about football
you know you don't want these games to
be played
and i said oh okay
i'm gonna now go to bed at 10 o'clock at
night and mail in my column okay instead
of staying up till 3 30 and writing
about a lot of stuff going on in the
league because
don't you remember i don't care about
football and i don't want it to be
played it's uh it's a funny thing that
people think sometimes oh we get
feedback all week why are you talking
about it because it's the top story in
the league they're dealing with an
outbreak an obvious outbreak in one city
they're worried about an outbreak in
another city and now in kansas city
they're holding their breath to see
whether or not the breath exchanged by
stefan gilmore and patrick mahomes may
have gotten mahomes infected another
another crop report clarence beaks is
back he's going to get a third check
this week from duke and duke
no new positives in kansas city either
remember they had a quarterback last
week jordan ta'amu who was positive
they've had no positive since then and
most importantly given the interaction
with the patriots on monday night and
specifically stefan gilmore no new
positives but again incubation period
people don't forget that it takes four
or five days for the virus to accumulate
to the point where you test pause it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports